so the white Wolf's teeth have finally
started the dull huh
if gerelds perks and mutations aren't
quite doing it for you anymore then
blood and wine might put some bite back
into that grumpy old Witcher The Witcher
threes final expansion is out apart from
the new region new quests and new
characters you also get your hands on
some deadly new mutations but first
things first you need to get to be clear
and pick up the turn and face the
strange side quest after you've
completed the first few main quest this
little kid should approach you with a
letter from yennefer dearest see what it
says here
postage-paid won't weasel any coin out
of me now scram I knew I should have
wiped dirt on that step bondage after
you make your way through the quest it's
time to get naked
seriously take off your clothes and hop
in this iron maiden looking thing now
it's time to start testing these highly
potent and dangerously lethal drugs
right on once you've completed this
quest you'll have access to a new
mutation skill tree before you start
plugging away at these new skills make
sure you have a decent amount of skill
points and lots and lots of greater
mutations if you're like me you probably
don't have many greater mutations before
you go and hunt for them check your
alchemy page in the menu using lesser
mutagens and standard mutagens you can
create greater mutagens to plug into
your new mutations if you're still short
for some reason drowners in Skellig i
almost always drop a lesser mutagen it's
a lot of grinding but hey it'll get the
job done now that that's taken care of
let's dive in there are three paths you
can follow once you open up the mutation
tree directly to the right we've got
alchemy these will require greater green
mutagens and skill points up to the top
is combat and for that you'll need
greater red mutagens and finally on the
left are signs you guessed it these will
require greater blue mutagens the
mutations located in between require
mutagens of whatever color they lie
between as well as the surrounding
mutations here are two of my favourite
mutations from blood and wine in action
first let's check out deadly counter
sword attacks deal extra damage and if
the attackers vitality is under 25% the
counter attack is automatically a
finisher
taken for the right alright enough of
that let's check out my favorite
piercing cold this is a variation on art
that can freeze opponents as is it's not
as much of a spectacle so I'd suggest
leveling up in equipping art sweep and
far-reaching art these are only two of
the twelve new mutations and as you
unlock more you also unlock more slots
to equip new perks if you have any tips
or combinations you like to rock with
these new skills let us know in the
comments below and if you want to geek
out about Witcher lore feel free to hit
me up on Twitter at Jacob deck and for
all you witches out there good luck on
the path
you